Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Incroyable !
Nous vivons une première
dans l’histoire de notre humanité :
la satisfaction de nos besoins actuels
repose pour plus de la moitié
sur des ressources du futur.
Autrement dit,
nous retirons aux générations de demain
le fait de pouvoir jouir
de ce dont on jouit actuellement,
le fait de pouvoir vivre
de manière heureuse,
et, sans doute pour certains êtres
humains, de vivre tout simplement.
La sauvegarde de la planète,
qu’elle reste habitable pour
les humains d’aujourd’hui et de demain,
est l’enjeu majeur de notre siècle.
Scientifiques, politiques,
associations, ONG,
de plus en plus de citoyens,
et notamment des jeunes,
en sont persuadés.
Et le temps presse
car les travaux du GIEC,
si longtemps déniés, décriés,
et ensuite jugés alarmistes,
ont sous-estimé la réalité.
Alors que font les entreprises ?
Rien ou trop peu.
La mise en œuvre de la responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises
est totalement insuffisante,
insatisfaisante.
Elle n’a pas empêché
le monde de se dégrader -
notre Terre, bien sûr, mais
également sur un plan social.
Et c’est dommage car si les entreprises
acceptaient d’être lucides,
elles pourraient être une force
de changement magnifique et pragmatique.
Elles savent décider rapidement.
Elles savent copier.
Elles savent adopter ce qui
fonctionne avec efficacité.
Elles savent se mettre en ordre de marche
et elles savent conduire le changement.
Il ne leur manque qu’une chose,
c’est un modèle dont s’inspirer.
Je vais vous faire une confidence :
je suis chef d’entreprise.
J’ai été salarié quelques années
mais sans trouver d’adéquation
avec mes valeurs.
Alors, en 1994, j’ai créé mon entreprise,
Une entreprise qui développe
des logiciels sur mesure
utilisant les nouvelles technologies,
qui développe des services numériques.
Nous sommes 650, en France et au Maroc.
Ça m’a été très utile d’être salarié
car ça m’a permis de mieux comprendre
les préoccupations des collaborateurs
en me mettant à leur place.
Cette entreprise,
j’ai cherché à la développer
en m’affranchissant de ce modèle
de maximisation des profits.
Ça me passionne
parce que ça nécessite d’essayer
de comprendre le monde,
d’être à l’écoute de ce qui émerge
mais qu’on ne voit pas encore,
d’anticiper de nouvelles
tendances sociales,
des mutations - technologiques,
numériques, écologiques.
Ça nécessite d'avoir une vision
globale de l'entreprise.
Je suis également impliqué,
engagé, dans une ONG
dont l’objet est de préserver
la planète : Greenpeace.
J'en anime le conseil d'administration
depuis onze ans.
Et j’ai toujours eu cette
préoccupation de la jeunesse
et de ses éventuelles difficultés.
Alors j’ai cherché à aider des jeunes
diplômés, mais discriminés,
avec ma fondation d'entreprise.
Ensuite, j’ai co-créé une association
dont l’objectif est de permettre
aux jeunes en rupture scolaire -
qu’on appelle les décrocheurs -
de devenir entrepreneurs de leur vie.
Elle s'appelle le réseau Étincelle.
Le fait d’être impliqué
dans le monde associatif
m’a certainement permis d’être plus lucide
sur les défis à relever,
des défis sociaux et sociétaux.
Mais ça m’a permis également de côtoyer
des personnes qui ne me ressemblent pas,
qui pensent ou vivent différemment.
C'est très utile.
Et ça m’a permis de mieux cerner
le rôle que l’entreprise
doit jouer dans la société.
Car l’entreprise peut mieux faire
pour améliorer l’existence
des êtres humains,
pour éviter de dégrader la planète,
elle en a les moyens.
Alors, 2019 est arrivé.
Je me suis remis en question à titre
personnel et comme chef d’entreprise.
On parle beaucoup de la crise des 40 ans,
moi, je l’ai faite à 60.
Je ne suis pas très précoce sur ce coup.
J’ai découvert qu’il existe
un modèle de production agricole
qui est très sensible
à la nature et aux humains :
la permaculture.
Savez-vous ce qu’est la permaculture ?
La permaculture est née
dans les années 70,
une époque où on commence
à prendre conscience que
les énergies fossiles, finalement,
les matières non renouvelables,
ne sont pas illimitées,
alors que toutes les entreprises, elles,
cherchent une croissance sans limite.
Deux Australiens, Bill Mollison
et David Holmgren,
préoccupés de la survie des populations
au cas où des ressources manqueraient,
décident de créer un nouveau modèle de
production agricole et de l’expérimenter.
Ils l’appellent la permaculture.
La permaculture ne nie pas
le fait de produire
ni de produire davantage,
qu’on peut appeler la croissance,
mais elle remet en cause, et de manière
radicale, les conditions de production,
en prônant un usage sobre et régénératif
des ressources utilisées.
Afin de le rendre efficace,
ils ont fait une fine observation
de la nature,
de ses interrelations, de ses écosystèmes.
Prenons un exemple.
Vous voulez récolter des courgettes,
des belles courgettes bien vertes.
Les pratiques de permaculture
vont dire : « Plantez des petits pois.
Ils piègent l’azote et permettent
à la terre de mieux se fertiliser.
Et mettez quelques oignons,
ça évitera les champignons parasitaires
qui vont dégrader votre courgette. »
C’est la magie des écosystèmes
de la nature.
La permaculture va au-delà
d’un mode de production.
C’est une philosophie de vie
qui s’articule autour de trois
principes éthiques indissociables :
prendre soin des hommes,
prendre soin du sol,
fixer des limites à la consommation
et redistribuer les surplus.
J’ai trouvé
que ces principes pouvaient être
exemplaires pour le monde de l’entreprise.
Il n’y avait aucune raison, finalement,
pour qu’on n’en fasse pas
des principes fondateurs et éthiques
d’une nouvelle vision de l’entreprise.
Alors -
J’ai lu ce livre de David Holmgren.
C'est du sérieux, vous voyez.
C’est écrit si petit que vous dites après
quelques pages : « Je verrai demain. »
Mais il y en a 650,
ça peut durer longtemps.
Ceci étant, à la fin de cette lecture,
j’ai décidé de créer un nouveau modèle
de développement d’entreprise
qui soit économiquement fiable,
mais pour un monde vivable.
Je l’ai appelé la permaentreprise.
Je me suis précipité à l’expérimenter
dans mon entreprise
parce que je me disais : « Est-ce
que mes intuitions sont bonnes ?
Est-ce que mes plus proches collaborateurs
qui dirigent l’entreprise avec moi
vont se l’approprier facilement,
vont aimer le porter ?
Est-ce que les autres collaborateurs vont
y trouver du sens, de l’enthousiasme ?
Ce modèle va-t-il permettre à l’entreprise
de plus s’engager sur les enjeux ?
Finalement, est-ce
qu’il va être efficace ? »
Cette expérimentation,
je l’avoue, a été un succès
et donc m’a conduit à rédiger un livre
qui décrit le modèle,
qui précise tous ces concepts,
et surtout qui propose une méthodologie
complète pour le mettre en œuvre,
mon but étant de le transmettre,
de l’essaimer.
La permaentreprise,
c’est un modèle qui s’appuie
sur trois principes éthiques
indissociables, incontournables :
prendre soin des êtres humains,
des femmes, des hommes ;
préserver la planète
et se fixer des limites
tout en redistribuant
équitablement les richesses.
Pour mettre ces principes en œuvre,
la permaentreprise propose
douze principes de conception
qui émanent de la permaculture
et que j’ai retranscrits
dans l’entreprise.
Quelques exemples.
Faire un usage sobre des ressources,
chercher à les régénérer,
utiliser des énergies renouvelables,
ne pas produire de déchets,
s’autoréguler,
avoir une vision globale de l’entreprise,
se réinventer en permanence.
Joli programme.
La permaentreprise intègre
également 23 objectifs d’impact.
Des objectifs qui imposent des seuils
à atteindre très exigeants,
mais qui vont faire
la crédibilité de l’entreprise
qui s’engage pour un monde meilleur.
Revenons à ces principes éthiques
fondateurs de la permaentreprise.
Le premier : prendre soin
des femmes et des hommes.
Cela passe en premier lieu par développer
un management centré sur l’humain.
Concrètement,
ne pas décider en fonction de soi,
mais en fonction de l’autre ;
être dans le dialogue,
dans l’ouverture d’esprit ;
accepter la diversité des points de vue ;
ne pas discriminer ;
mettre en place un contexte pour que
chacun puisse prendre des initiatives,
être autonome dans son travail, créer un
environnement source d’auto-motivation.
Mais ce principe - prendre
soin des êtres humains -
ouvre des perspectives par le concept
de régénération des ressources humaines.
Nous l’avons traduit sous deux aspects.
Le premier, c’est de faire en sorte
que pour tous les salariés,
il y ait des dispositifs qui leur
permettent d’améliorer leur employabilité.
En ce qui nous concerne,
ça s’est concrétisé par la mise
en place d’écoles par métiers -
l’école du développeur, du chef
de projet, etc. - sur plusieurs années.
Vous direz :
« L’entreprise a tout à y gagner.
Elle fait en sorte
que chacun soit plus efficace. »
Certes, mais ce qui est le plus important,
c’est que lorsqu’un salarié quitte
une entreprise, quel que soit le motif,
il puisse retrouver un emploi
rapidement et sereinement.
La deuxième perspective liée à cette
régénération des ressources humaines,
nous l’avons traduite par le fait d’être
en énergie positive de manière permanente
en cultivant les leviers
de qualité de vie.
Je vais vous prendre
un exemple d’actualité.
En 2015, nous avions mis
en place le télétravail,
notre objectif étant
de renforcer les dispositifs
pour que chacun trouve
le meilleur équilibre
entre la vie professionnelle
et la vie personnelle.
Mais je dois avouer,
quand je vous parlais d’anticiper
des tendances sociales,
que sur ce coup-là, nous avons eu raison
puisque finalement le télétravail,
qu’aucune entreprise ne voulait,
s’est imposé du jour au lendemain
de manière très brutale.
Et combien de salariés ont été stressés
dans l’inconfort par cette brutalité.
Plus récemment, nous avons proposé
à des salariés de dire :
« Donnez-nous d’autres idées
pour être en énergie positive,
des dispositifs qui soient
sources d’énergie positive. »
Et ils nous ont étonnés.
Ils nous ont dit : « Nous voulons
être reconnectés à la nature
pendant notre travail. »
Alors nous avons à nouveau expérimenté :
bains de forêt,
visites de fermes en mutation écologique,
implantation d’un jardin en permaculture
sur un de nos sites,
ateliers de potager, etc.
Sources d’un bel enthousiasme tout cela.
Le deuxième principe éthique est
donc de préserver la planète.
Le dérèglement climatique
et la perte de biodiversité
sont de très grands dangers
pour notre humanité.
Le modèle de permaentreprise pousse
donc les entreprises à agir
et en priorité sur deux aspects.
Le premier, c’est une réduction
drastique des émissions de CO2.
Et le deuxième, c'est d'être en
contribution nette et positive de carbone
dans une période de 5 à 10 ans.
Voilà un exemple d'objectif d'impact.
Nous cherchons à le faire
depuis quelques années,
notamment en réduisant
nos déplacements professionnels,
car ils représentaient 60% de nos
émissions de CO2 dans notre bilan carbone.
À ce titre, le télétravail
est très efficace.
Nous avons également aussi développé
un logiciel qui permet à chaque salarié
de connaître son propre bilan carbone
professionnel, de le suivre au quotidien,
notre objectif étant de renforcer leur
prise de conscience sur ce sujet,
mais également de leur donner
envie d’être acteurs.
Pour réduire leurs émissions et pour
adopter de nouvelles méthodes de travail
comme l’éco-conception, ou de
participer à des plantations de forêts
pour être en compensation carbone.
Sur ce dernier point, nous voulons
aller beaucoup plus loin.
Nous voulons financer
des puits de carbone.
Un exemple ?
Nous soutenons une entreprise agricole
qui n’a pas les moyens de remettre
en cause son système de production
alors que ça baisserait largement
ses émissions de CO2.
Eh bien, nous lui finançons
et nous lui donnons les moyens.
Le troisième principe éthique :
se fixer des limites et redistribuer
équitablement les richesses.
Ce principe s’appuie notamment
sur d’autres objectifs d’impact.
Le premier : faire en sorte
qu’il n’y ait plus d’écart
entre les salaires hommes-femmes
à compétences égales ;
faire en sorte de réduire l’écart
entre les salaires les plus élevés
et le salaire médian.
Redistribuer 50% des résultats
de l’entreprise aux collaborateurs
et à la société civile, impôts compris.
Le reste allant à l’actionnaire
et aux investissements nécessaires
au développement de l’entreprise.
C’est ce qui nous a permis,
cette redistribution,
de financer notre fondation
d’entreprise depuis 20 ans,
qui, notamment, cherche
à soutenir des projets associatifs
qui luttent contre l’injustice sociale ou
pour des problématiques d’environnement.
Dernièrement,
cette redistribution nous a permis
de créer l’Institut du permanumérique
et de financer des projets de recherche
qui visent évidemment à ce que
le numérique soit moins émetteur de CO2.
Je vais vous faire une révélation.
Toutes les entreprises qui ont adopté
ce modèle sont performantes,
voire plus performantes que les autres.
Pourquoi ?
En premier lieu, elles sont plus
attractives pour recruter des talents.
Et elle fidélise davantage
les collaborateurs.
Ils ont une forte attente,
notamment sur les engagements de
l’entreprise au regard de la planète.
Le modèle permaentreprise y répond.
Mais dans le contexte actuel,
où il y a tant de secteurs d’activité
qui manquent de ressources,
être davantage attractifs
que les autres, fidéliser davantage,
c’est une source
de performance incroyable.
Cette attractivité, on la retrouve
aussi chez des clients
qui peu à peu cherchent à travailler avec
des fournisseurs véritablement engagés.
Un autre levier de performance,
c'est l'innovation.
Le fait de s’interroger
sur les mutations à venir,
d’anticiper des problématiques
sociales, environnementales,
pousse à innover.
Or, l'innovation est souvent
source de performance.
Et enfin, ce modèle fait
faire des économies.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’il réduit
fortement les coûts cachés,
notamment du turn over, mais
également du désengagement de salariés,
de l’absentéisme,
des maladies professionnelles, etc.
Le modèle de développement des entreprises
d’aujourd’hui est dépassé.
Il nous faut absolument un nouveau modèle
qui réponde aux défis du XXIᵉ siècle.
Le modèle de permaentreprise
n’est pas une utopie.
Nous le pratiquons depuis plusieurs années
et aujourd’hui, plus de 120 entreprises
se sont lancées dans son adoption.
Alors, imaginez que dans quelques années,
des milliers d’entreprises se développent
en prenant soin des hommes et des femmes,
en préservant la planète,
en se fixant des limites
et en redistribuant les richesses.
Imaginez que des milliers
d’entreprises se développent
avec un usage sobre et régénératif
de leurs ressources.
Imaginez que vous puissiez créer
ou travailler dans une entreprise
qui soit économiquement fiable,
mais pour un futur vivable.
Associons nos énergies,
travaillons pour l’adapter
à d’autres entreprises,
de toutes tailles, des associations,
des ONG, des entreprises publiques,
des organisations humaines,
parce que ces principes sont universels.
Ce modèle ne demande
qu’à être expérimenté.
Alors, soyons entre prises.
La prise avec ce monde d’aujourd’hui,
ce monde que nous ne voulons plus,
ce monde que nous voulons changer,
abandonnons-la, lâchons-la.
Par contre,
saisissons ce modèle de permaentreprise
pour un monde meilleur
et surtout ne le lâchons plus.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)